Petra this is your fourth time returning
to crap my fourth time um well like it's
technically third time okay we had done
a crowdfunding campaign for to
crowdfunding campaigns for the sous and
this is the third okay yeah is this
something you're excited about or do you
realize how much works out of you with
the crowdfunding campaign am I excited
about the crowdfunding campaign you know
i'm i'm excited to the extent that i
know that this is much better way to
finance films i have financed previous
films through investors money and wow
that's been less work because
crime-fighting kind of funding as we all
know a lot of work it usually means that
i don't make as much money on the film's
because i have to pay back all the
profits that come in on the film and
still paying back profits on name i
found my projects so i'm excited that
that we're doing the crowdfunding
campaign because you know it'll help
with the investor burden and it is
deciding to sort of get the word out
about the film and build this sort of
following around the film and that's
very exciting to get the feedback from
people but yeah I'm not too excited
about the work itself you know it's
there's so much that that filmmakers
have to do that doesn't involve
filmmaking and you know crowdfunding is
like it's a full-time job while you're
running a campaign it very much is so
you know it's it's it's it's challenging
it's challenging but it's fun it's fun
getting to getting the word out and
talking to people about the film and you
know we're creating teasers that we're
releasing on a semi weekly basis to
tobacker Xand so that's kind of fun and
it all kind of helps me develop the idea
even further which is which is kind of
nice as well so yeah it's all good
you